[Musique]
et avant votre analyse Benjamin on va
regarder ce qui se dessine comme le
nouvel hémicycle du Sénat alors c'est
évidemment à prendre avec des
précautions puisque les sénateurs ne se
sont pas encore rattachés officiellement
à des groupes mais d'après les
déclarations des présidents de groupe
les républicains perdent quelques sièges
trois à quatre les centristes eux en
gagnent le même nombre les socialistes
devraient gagner aussi un ou deux sièges
les écologistes 4 les communistes deux
ou trois et Renaissance en perdre
quelques-uns mais selon François Patriat
ne devait pas descendre en dessous de 20
ils étaient 24 dans le précédent
hémicycle et puis le rassemblement
national fait donc son retour au Sénat
et contrat trois sénateurs ces
sénatoriales qui sont donc marqués par
une relative stabilité on garde les
principaux enseignements de ce scrutin
avec Laura sauvage
sans surprise la droite garde la
majorité au Sénat même si le père
quelques sénateurs le parti a l'air
parvient à conserver sa main mise sur la
haute assemblée en gardant la majorité
absolue avec ses alliés centristes dans
le département du Nord les républicains
perdent un siège au profit du
rassemblement national on aurait voulu
faire nos deux sièges on en fait qu'à
mais enfin on résiste bien puisque le
score qu'on fait montre qu'on tient
toujours nos positions avec trois
nouveaux sénateurs dans le Nord le
Pas-de-Calais et la Seine-et-Marne le RN
signe son retour au Palais du Luxembourg
même s'il ne pourra pas former de
groupes politiques car il faut un
minimum de 10 sénateurs ce qui n'empêche
pas l'enthousiasme de Joshua Hochard
heureux de cette élection du premier
sénateur à son nom national dans le nord
du deuxième dans le dans le
Pas-de-Calais parce que mon collègue a
été élu également j'accueille cette
élections avec avec humilité puisque la
tâche qui nous attend pour les 6
prochaines années et grandes à gauche le
nombre de sénateurs socialistes se
maintient et reste le premier groupe de
position dans le Val-de-Marne l'ancienne
ministre et sénatrice de l'Oise Laurence
Rossignol est réélu malgré son
parachutage on va ensemble
éthique du gouvernement au Sénat
et sénatorial
mais Paris l'union de la gauche porte
ses fruits l'euro député écologiste
Yannick Jadot était élu moi je vais être
au Sénat pour à la fois porter tout le
projet écologiste sur l'immigration sur
la décentralisation sur la
proportionnelle mais faire en sorte que
la France soit la hauteur du défi
écologique enfin du côté de la majorité
présidentielle théorisons le parti
d'Édouard Philippe gagne quelques sièges
Renaissance perd des plumes principales
déconvenue la défaite de la secrétaire
d'État à la citoyenneté Sonia bac S en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et cette Dalin
Richard dans le Val-d'Oise et les
réactions politiques assez résultant ont
été nombreuses on en écoute
quelques-unes avec Marion Delpech
les résultats des élections sénatoriales
confirment la stabilité de la chambre
haute dominée par la droite malgré une
perte des effectifs du groupe les
républicains très peu de sénateurs 3 ou
4 sénateurs et ça n'est pas encore
définitif on en gagne dans la Moselle on
en gagne en Isère donc je trouve que
c'est plutôt une performance dans les
temps politiques qui courent le groupe
centriste
chez lui de plusieurs membres à
l'évidence on va gagner quelques
quelques sièges qui va effectivement
asseoir davantage encore la majorité au
Sénat et qui va aussi enrichir la
diversité en effectif déjà réduit au
Sénat les macronistes payent leurs
faibles en crash local le groupe
contrairement à ce que nous apprend-il
de descendre pas demain au dessous de 20
je pense que c'est une belle résistance
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui le contexte politique dans
le contexte qui est évoqué aujourd'hui
dans l'environnement après tout ce soir
je peux dire que je respire un peu enfin
le rassemblement national fait son
retour au Sénat c'est une deuxième
victoire la première c'est de faire
entrer trois sénateurs ça démarre Nord
et Pas de Calais trois jeunes élus trois
élus de terrain et la seconde c'est les
scores que nous faisons qui je crois
bouscule beaucoup évidemment ce qui
était attendu parallèlement la bonne
tenue de la gauche danseuse scrutant
notamment à Paris consolide le clivage
gauche-droite au sein de la Chambre
haute
[Musique]
la réaction à cette phrase de Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat qui a été
réélu hier sénateur des Yvelines le
Sénat continuera à être ce
contre-pouvoir indispensable à la
démocratie oui c'est pas tout à fait
neutre parce que la notion de
contre-pouvoir elle est toujours un peu
problématique on a un sénat qui à la
fois et en effet un contre-pouvoir sur
certains sujets mais participent
également pouvoir s'il est législateur
et donc ce faisant Gérard Larcher a
toujours utilisé ce mot tout en nuant
donc là on voit que quand même il y a
une affirmation qui est une affirmation
à qu'on a un sénat d'opposition et que
même si vous avez un groupe LR et un
groupe centriste qui peuvent rentrer
dans une négociation sur les textes
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron a besoin du
Sénat il a besoin que les textes soient
adoptés au Sénat pour qu'ensuite ils
arrivent dans une version acceptable
notamment par la droite à l'Assemblée
nationale la seconde chambre a vraiment
un rôle centrale aujourd'hui lors de la
dernière session ordinaire on a eu que
trois derniers mots donc on arrive dans
une situation où en réalité et bien le
bicamérisme inégalitaire est aujourd'hui
fondamentalement annoncé cette situation
là n'empêche pas le Sénat d'avoir une
majorité de droite avec quelques
sénateurs de la majorité qui peuvent
faire les yeux à la macronie mais qui
malgré tout s'encre fondamentalement
dans son immense majorité dans
l'opposition un mot puisque vous parlez
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a pris la parole
hier soir à 20h soir d'élection
sénatoriale soit de résultats avec en
plus on se trompe sur le renouvellement
du Sénat vous dites Emmanuel Macron il a
besoin du Sénat c'est un mauvais signal
qui est envoyé au sénateur qui vont
s'installer lundi alors j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre en effet le sens de
cette interview parce que ce qui a été
annoncé aurait pu être annoncé ailleurs
voir par d'autres et ensuite et bien
faire cette interview le soir d'une
sénatoriale c'est évidemment montrer une
forme de mépris pour un moment électoral
qui aurait gagné à ne pas être éclipsé
par cette interview qui plus est se
tromper sur quelque chose qui relève
quand même de la base quand on connaît
un peu les assemblées parlementaires ces
problématique donc lorsque vous voulez
tant de la main à la majorité satariale
dont il a encore une fois besoin il n'a
pas réellement choix et bien c'est pas
la meilleure façon c'est pas la
meilleure entrée en matière avec la
nouvelle composition du Sénat pas sûr
que hier dans le meilleur cas dans le
meilleur des cas ça s'en a fait rire
certains je pense que ça en a agac é
beaucoup d'autres on va rentrer dans le
détail des résultats allez l'un des
faits notables de cette soirée c'est le
retour du rassemblement national au
Sénat parmi les trois sénateurs élus
deux l'ont été dans les hauts de France
le nord et le Pas-de-Calais on va
justement à Lille dans le Nord retrouver
Samia de cher bonjour Samia merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin ça
vient on le disait de sénateurs ont été
élus dans les hauts de France
oui bonjour Oriane on peut dire
effectivement que le parti a fait une
vraie percée dans la région en
confirmant une implantation désormais
solide dans les hauts de France puisque
vous le disiez c'est ici qu'il a réussi
à faire élire deux des candidats du
rassemblement national qui vont faire
leur entrée au Sénat alors dans le
Pas-de-Calais d'abord on s'y attendait
un peu Christopher Zurich a réussi à
gagner son siège au Palais du Luxembourg
il a 38 ans c'est le premier adjoint de
Steve Briois à la mairie
d'Hénin-Beaumont le fief de Marine Le
Pen Marine Le Pen qui d'ailleurs est
venu le soutenir en personne pendant sa
campagne Christopher Zurich il était au
micro hier soir de Jonathan Dupriez et
Gaspard flamand Arras pour Public Sénat
regardez
je suis évidemment heureux je suis
extrêmement fier je suis très satisfait
aussi si on parle vraiment des résultats
en eux-mêmes parce que finalement je
double mon résultat par rapport à 2017
j'arrive en troisième position ce qui
était pas forcément attendu ni par moi
ni par les autres ce qui veut dire aussi
que j'ai réussi à rassembler que le
rassemblement national a réussi à
rassembler largement au-delà de ses
seuls grands électeurs il y a forcément
je pense et je l'avais bien senti
pendant la campagne des électeurs issus
de toutes les formations politiques des
élus non étiquetés qui nous ont accordé
leur confiance et ça c'est sans doute
aussi une grande victoire aujourd'hui
autre victoire pour le rassemblement
national dans le département voisin du
Nord ici à Lille ce n'était pas
forcément gagné pour lui mais Joshua
Hochard a réussi à s'imposer il a 36 ans
il est élu municipal à Denain et c'est
un proche de Sébastien Chenu Joshua et
donc désormais sénateur du rassemblement
national pour le Nord tout comme
Christopher Duret ils sont deux et c'est
la première fois que les hauts de France
élisent des sénateurs d'extrême droite
merci Samia merci beaucoup on vous
retrouve un peu plus tard évidemment
dans cette émission Benjamin l'un des
enseignements de la soirée c'est le
retour du rassemblement national au
Sénat avec un nombre inédit de sénateurs
trois sénateurs c'est quoi la preuve de
la notabilisation du parti absolument il
faut pas s'arrêter aux trois sénateurs
parce qu'en effet c'est un retour il y a
quelques années ils en avaient deux
quelques uns sont partis à reconquête
donc ça qui est trois sénateurs je
dirais c'est pas si étonnant on aurait
même pu en imaginer un peu plus et ce
n'est pas si nouveau en revanche ce qui
est très très marquant c'est le nombre
de votes pour le rassemblement national
je parlais tout à l'heure de signaux
faibles au Sénat les choses avancent
lentement vous avez des départements
dans lesquels et bien le score du RN a
été jusqu'à 15% des grands électeurs
jadis pour des grands électeurs il faut
bien voir que les élections locales
favorisent les centrices tout bêtement
parce que participation différentielle
c'est plutôt le lectoratrice qui va
hauter à ces élections locales donc le
corps des élus locaux et en règle
générale très rétif au voteren là pour
beaucoup de ces conseillers municipaux
ces mers etc et bien le département
ayant voté majoritairement RN aux
dernières législatives le député RN
point important s'étant implanter
faisant entre guillemets le job du point
au niveau local c'est rend la main de
Monsieur le Préfet allant à 11
inauguration au foires etc et bien
l'idée qu'il pourrait y avoir un
sénateur rassemblement national est venu
est devenu quelque chose de possible
d'audibles et ça ça signifie beaucoup
par la banalisation réussite Marine Le
Pen c'est la banalisation en effet la
normalisation du rassemblement national
parmi ces élus locaux qui forcément sont
plus politisés que la moyenne est plus
informée que la moyenne et puis par
ailleurs ça veut dire que demain
certains membres pourraient venir
enrichir le rassemblement national lors
des élections locales vous voyez que là
il y a aujourd'hui une porosité une
capacité à recruter potentiellement dans
ce corps des élus locaux qui fait que
l'implantation du RN est bien ancrée
commence bien et que demain elle peut
même s'accroître avec des ralliements de
6 de là et donc on a un qui s'inscrit
dans le paysage est-ce que ça découle
aussi des législatives avec des élus
locaux qui se sont adibles le
rassemblement national a fait tel score
dans ma commune difficile pour moi de ne
pas donner un signal au sénatorial oui
alors lors des dernières municipales on
a certains endroits où vous avez une
hausse en effet du voterenne plus d'élus
mais ça n'explique pas ce que l'on a vu
dans pas mal de départements donc en
effet c'est d'un côté la pression
électorale jadis quand vous étiez un nez
de local vous disiez oui mais bon mes
électeurs ne me pardonneraient pas si je
savais que je voter RN etc aujourd'hui
ce tabou a clairement sauté et de
l'autre côté même plutôt l'inverse
c'est-à-dire vous avez cette pression
évidemment populaire et de l'autre côté
encore une fois le travail fait par les
députés
élu il y a moins d'un an au niveau local
a été importante ce qui montre
qu'aujourd'hui et bien il n'est plus
possible pour beaucoup d'élus locaux de
ne pas rentrer en dialogue avec le
député de la circo qui est un député ARN
et que donc ce faisant l'idée d'avoir un
autre représentant national qui est RN
avec quelque chose qui ne choque plus en
tout cas pour une partie d'entre eux
les gagnants les
personnes poussent à nous rejoindre
bonjour Alex merci d'être avec nous ce
matin Alex vous allez intervenir
régulièrement pour nous faire le point
sur les résultats sur les personnalités
élus et on commence par les gagnants de
ce scrutinex et bien Oriane la première
personnalité gagnante de ces
sénatoriales c'est genre à l'archer le
président du Sénat qui a été réélu
sénateur dans les Yvelines pour un
sixième mandat sa majorité de droite et
du centre au Sénat reste stable et il
devrait être réélu sans encombre à la
tête de la Haute Assemblée dans cette
majorité sénatoriale il y a un autre
gagnant c'est Hervé Marseille le
président du groupe centriste au Sénat
il a été élu dans les Hauts-de-Seine et
son groupe centriste et bien gagne
quelques sièges au terme de ce scrutin
une personnalité a des républicains
c'est imposé hier soir c'est Philippe
Bas réélu sénateur de la Manche pour un
troisième mandat on le rappelle Philippe
Bas était le président de la commission
des Lois du Sénat et le président de la
fameuse commission
sur l'affaire Benalla alors à gauche qui
sont les personnalités gagnantes de ces
élections sénatoriales et bien on peut
citer Patrick canner le président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat il a été élu
dans le Nord son groupe socialiste reste
stable voire même pour être conforté
mais attention patrickner va devoir
batailler pour garder la présidence de
son groupe face à Eric kerrouch sénateur
qui est plutôt favorable à la ligne
politique de la nupes autre gagnant à
gauche Guillaume gonta président du
groupe écologiste réélu dans l'Isère son
groupe écologiste sort lui vraiment
renforcé de ces sénatoriales et devrait
passer de 12 à 16 sièges de sénateurs et
puis enfin autre personnalité gagnante
on peut citer l'ancienne ministre de
François Hollande puis d'Emmanuel Macron
Annick Girardin qui fait son entrée au
Sénat elle a été élu sénatrice de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon merci Alex vous
revenez très vite pour nous parler des
perdants cette fois forcément merci à
tout à l'heure on va continuer notre
tour de France des résultats on va à
Metz
c'est indéniablement le fait politique à
retenir dans cette sénatoriale ici en
Moselle le ticket Jean-Marie maison
apparenté Union Centriste et Catherine
belleretti les républicains réussi à
faire élire un troisième sénateur sur
cette liste de droite alors si les deux
sortent en pouvaient raisonnablement
nourrir des espoirs d'être réélu réussir
à faire élire et emmener un troisième
sénateur de droite en la personne du
premier adjoint de la mairie de Metz
docteur Khalifé qualifié un véritable
tour de force une union qui porte ses
fruits et qui doit appeler à plus de
coopération entre les composantes de la
majorité sénatoriale si l'on en croit
Jean-Marie maison
nous avons toujours eu des moments de
tension mais il faut que ça reste des
moments il y a quantité de sujets sur
lesquelles nous pouvons nous retrouver
nous devons nous retrouver pour faire
triomphé nos valeurs et nos idées et ma
foi ça se fera pas toujours dans la
facilité mais la politique c'est ça
aussi c'est convaincre c'est discuté
échanger pour trouver des points de
convergence qui le fassent que que des
gens heureux dans la dans les deux
parties de cette majorité
deuxième dans l'ordre d'arriver le
premier fédéral de Moselle socialiste
Michael Weber qui a réussi à rallier une
partie des communistes du département
réussi à récupérer numériquement le
siège du sortant Jean-Marc todéchini
ancien ministre socialiste autre sorte
Christine erzog réussi cette fois à se
faire élire sur son nom elle qui est
l'ancienne colystère de Jean-Louis
Masson et qui avait basé sa campagne sur
ses différences avec son ancien
colistier à noter toutefois qu'elle ne
compte qu'une cinquantaine de voix de
plus que Anne boucher la candidate
horizon qui est ici beaucoup à qui ici
beaucoup prêtait des espoirs d'arriver
au Sénat
merci beaucoup merci Mathias d'avoir été
avec nous depuis la Moselle Mathias le
disait l'Union de la Droite et du centre
a été payante en Moselle alors l'Union
de la Droite et du centre se maintient
au Sénat on le disait il y a une
stabilité mais Benjamin vous ne l'avez
dit tout à l'heure tout se joue dans les
détails les LR perdent un peu les
centristes eux gagnent un peu est-ce que
ça peut changer des choses dans
l'équilibre de la majorité sénatoriale
alors ça peut changer quelques petites
choses c'est à dire que les rapports de
force au sein de cette majorité qui est
encore quelques années étaient fortement
dominé par elle qui est le seul groupe
enfin j'addition MP qui a pu avoir une
majoritaire absolue dans cette chambre
sous la Cinquième République et ben
aujourd'hui tourne un petit peu à
l'avantage des centrist c'est son triste
ne sont pas tout à fait sur la même
ligne que LR on le voit notamment sur ce
projet de loi immigration qui
aujourd'hui crée de vrais tensions entre
les deux groupes par ailleurs et bien
vous avez un groupe centriste qui est
beaucoup plus divers il y a des
composantes qui peuvent être des
composantes très proches de la majorité
présidentielle donc forcément ça
rééquilibre la majorité pour l'instant
ça n'aura pas d'impact majeur en
revanche et bien on va parler
être élections au plateau Gérard Larcher
sera réélu sur un plateau sans trop de
problèmes mais la question qui se pose
c'est qui après lui peut potentiellement
réunir cette majorité qui devient de
plus en plus hétéroclite entre un groupe
LR qui tente de plus en plus vers la
droite dont le point d'équilibre et bien
se déplace vers la droite pour des
raisons qu'on peut comprendre
d'équilibrer électoraux et de l'autre
côté un groupe centriste qui lui langue
de plus en plus vers le centre donc
aujourd'hui cette majorité très très
composite elle tient un grand parti par
nécessité elle tient un grand parti
également par Gérard Larcher la question
de sa cohésion en revanche se pose plus
qu'il y a quelques années on va aller
dans un territoire où la droite partait
diviser très divisé ses Paris où on
retrouve Steve Jourdain Steve bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous alors on
le disait la droite partie divisée la
gauche elle partait unie et elle a
réussi une démonstration de force hier à
Paris
oui un dimanche parfait pour la gauche
parisienne la gauche parisienne qui
partait unie puisque vous le voyez
derrière moi c'est l'hôtel de ville
l'hôtel de ville et bien qui est composé
d'une alliance écologiste socialiste et
communiste autour de la mer de Paris
Anne Hidalgo si cette même alliance qui
s'avançait uni pour ces élections
sénatoriales et qui donc parvient à
remporter huit sièges de sénateurs elle
en avait jusque là 7 c'est donc un très
très bon résultat nidalgo et bien
évidemment venu à notre micro hier soir
pour se féliciter de ce très bon score
et adresser un petit tac à son opposante
bien-aimée Rachida Dati il y aura et
bien quelques nouveaux visages dans
cette assemblée sénatoriale puisque vous
en parliez tout à l'heure Yannick Jadot
fait son entrée au Sénat l'écologie
ancien candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il y a aussi Yann brossa
l'adjoint communiste ici à la mairie de
Paris en charge des questions de
logement on trouve aussi Colombes
Brussel l'adjointe en charge des de
propreté ici encore à la mairie de Paris
à droite vous disiez on partait très
divisé puisqu'il y avait pas moins de
trois listes sur la ligne de départ on
craignait une départdition des voix ça
ne sera pas ça n'a pas été le cas
puisque elle a droite parvient à
conserver et bien c'est 4 sièges de
sénateurs un mot sur la majorité
présidentielle qui n'avait qu'un seul
siège ici à Paris et bien ce siège
n'existe plus puisque Julien barjetton
le sénateur Renaissance n'est pas
parvenu et bien convaincre les grands
électeurs en résumé Oriane la gauche
fait cartons plein la droite résiste et
la majorité présidentielle et
littéralement rayé de la carte ici à
Paris c'est un scrutin important
évidemment et bien pour le palais du
Luxembourg mais ce sera aussi
intéressant de voir comment les choses
vont évoluer parce que c'était peut-être
le premier tour en vue des élections
municipales de 2026 et de l'éventuelle
succession d'Anne Hidalgo effectivement
on suivra tout ça si vous vous retrouvez
un petit peu plus tard dans cette
émission merci beaucoup alors l'occasion
de parler à gauche la gauche qui a
réussi un carton carton plein pour la
Gauche à Paris qui fait lire huit
sénateurs sur les 12 sièges elle prouve
quoi que l'union fait la force mais sans
la France insoumise oui elle aurait même
pu mordre un neuvième c'est à dire que
la question à un moment s'est posée le
mode de scrutin favorise de toute façon
l'Union tous les modes de scrutin en
réalité favorisent plutôt l'Union dès
lors que vous contrôlez à peu près votre
électorat ce qui est le cas en milieu
urbain et c'est quelqu'un notamment pour
la Gauche à Paris donc en effet c'est un
très très bon score et ce très très bon
score et bien il est dans il permet à la
gauche je dirais à la fois d'augmenter
son nombre de membres Sénat mais
également de changer quelques équilibres
parce que d'un côté vous avez un groupe
socialiste qui malgré tout stagne de
l'autre côté vous avez une montée des
Verts une montée des communistes et ça
et bien c'est également une conséquence
de ces listes d'union la France
insoumise ne trouble pas vraiment le jeu
à Paris mais toutefois il faut quand
même regarder dans le détail cette
élection si vous regardez dans beaucoup
de départements les listes France
insoumises n'ont pas fait de gros score
mais elles ont fait un score peut-être
plus important que ce on aurait pu
croire ce qui montre que et bien il y a
quand même quelques ressources locales
pour la fi même en opposition aux autres
parties de la gauche et ces listes d'AFI
ont quand même fait perdre quelques
sièges et de la gauche aurait pu avoir
un petit peu plus de sénateurs hier soir
si jamais il y avait pas eu ces listes
et les filles elles ont fait perdre des
sièges parce qu'on entendait des gens de
gauche au LFI dire que les divisions ont
coûté des leurres coûté des sièges et
elle a fi qui dans un communiqué dit que
en refusant l'Union autour de la nuque
la gauche a perdu une dizaine de sièges
au Sénat les deux interprétations sont
possibles et il est vrai que la fi n'a
pas vraiment beaucoup des locaux voire
qu'elle n'en a même quasiment pas du
tout et que donc lui donner une place au
Sénat aurait pu être contestable par
ailleurs mais il faut voir que le corps
des élus locaux le corps électoral du
Sénat est encore quand même qu'il a une
plutôt vers le centre structurellement
égard à la participation différentielle
etc donc envoyer un candidat à la fi
c'est pas certain que beaucoup d'éluses
ont inscrit vous suivent donc ça aurait
pu être un risque pour la gauche combien
même il est pas ensuite des Bizzbee au
sein de la nuque ça c'est évidemment un
autre problème mais la fille n'a pas non
plus tout à fait tort en disant que ben
il est légitime de présenter des
candidats dès lors qu'on vous refuse
dans la liste commune et que donc ce
faisant ces candidatures pour un grand
parti national était légitime et que si
la gauche le reste de la gauche voulait
les éviter bah il fallait les intégrer
les deux interprétations s'entend on va
continuer à parler les résultats Alex
va nous rejoindre à un nouveau Alex tout
à l'heure on a vu les gagnants les élus
mais comme dans toute l'élection il y a
des grands perdants et oui avec quelques
perdants du côté de la majorité
présidentielle et d'abord l'actuel
secrétaire d'État la citoyenneté Sonia
bacquez qui a été battue en
Nouvelle-Calédonie à sa place c'est un
indépendant néocalédonien qui va faire
son entrée au Sénat l'ancienne ministre
de la Santé d'Emmanuel Macron Brigitte
bourguignon a également été battu
c'était dans le Pas-de-Calais une
nouvelle défaite après l'échec de
Brigitte bourguignon au dernier
législatives c'était dans 2022 et puis
le parti Renaissance Steve l'a dit perd
son seul sénateur à Paris julien
barjetton n'a pas réussi à conserver son
siège face à une liste d'union de la
gauche entre socialistes écologiste et
communiste qui a fait un très bon score
et puis parfois les défaites électorales
se jouent à rien le sénateur renaissance
du Val-d'Oise Alain Richard ancien
ministre de la défense de Lionel Jospin
a été battu hier à deux voies près il va
donc quitter le Sénat à droite il y a
aussi des déçus parmi certaines
personnalités le sénateur les
républicains de l'Oise Jérôme Bacher a
été battu victime des divisions de la
droite dans son département et puis une
figure de la droite parisienne le
sarkoziste Pierre Charron va aussi
quitter la Haute Assemblée il a été
battu après avoir essayé de mener une
liste de droites dissidentes dans la
capitale merci Alex à tout à l'heure les
perdants de la soirée c'est la majorité
présidentielle et plus particulièrement
Renaissance Benjamin c'est plus
particulièrement Renaissance en effet
plus que la majorité présidentielle là
je dirais c'est le résultat de deux
éléments d'abord Renaissance s'est
constitué au Sénat essentiellement par
bien le fait de récupérer des sénateurs
qui émanaient d'autres groupes or le
problème c'est que vous pouvez ramener
des sénateurs vous ramenez pas forcément
leurs grands électeurs et donc si vous
n'êtes pas ensuite une stratégie
d'ancrage et bien votre sénateur il
plane un petit peu sur ses connaissances
et son réseau personnel mais pas sur une
mobilisation de grands é et ça forcément
notamment en milieu urbain ça ne
pardonne pas donc il faut mener cette
stratégie d'ancrage cette stratégie
d'ancrage elle n'a pas vraiment été
menée où elle était très peu habilement
menée lors des élections locales donc là
Renaissance paye je dirais les
municipales les départementales les
régionales de l'autre côté vous avez
d'autres composants de la majorité qui
elle ont fait cet effort d'encrage ou
bien ont été chercher des élus qui
pouvaient mobiliser des réseaux
notamment au centre droit commencez par
horizon je pensais évidemment horizon et
là on verra ce qu'il va en être parce
que là c'est la première manche en
réalité de la bataille de ces
dessinatoriales l'autre manche ça va
être la composition des groupes et
ensuite l'élection des présidents
élection sénatoriale d'horizon puisque
c'est un tout jeune persil partie
d'Edouard Philippe est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il a réussi son pari est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir un rééquilibrage dans
la majorité présidentielle avec ce
résultat on verra la composition du
groupe horizon s'il y en a priori
devrait y en avoir un mais il en effet
possible que ce groupe horizon soit
conséquent qu'il puisse tenir la dragée
haute au groupe l'un des pays de de de
chapatria est proche d'Emmanuel Macron
si c'est le cas on a quand même un
groupe qui peut être intéressant pour
Édouard Philippe parce que c'est un
groupe qui objectivement est passé
éloigné de la composante centriste de la
majorité statoriale n'est pas très
éloignée de l'Union centriste peut donc
faire les ponts entre les deux mondes
majorité parlementaires
majorité sénatoriale et majorité
présidentielle et donc c'est un groupe
qui est un groupe pivot c'est un groupe
qui est un groupe intéressant c'est un
groupe qui est un peu avoir une
influence de main alors que comme on le
disait tout à l'heure Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui qui le veuille ou non et ben
il a besoin du Sénat allez on poursuit
notre tour de France des résultats on va
à présent à Saint-Étienne dans la Loire
retrouvée Anthony verpillon bonjour
Anthony merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à TL7 c'est la télévision
locale dans la Loire Anthony qui sont
les quatre sénateurs élus du côté de
chez vous
et bien les quatre sénateurs élus on va
commencer peut-être avec les deux
sortants qui ont été réélu Cécile
picardman pour le Parti communiste
français et puis Jean-Claude Petit Saut
pour agir pour la loi ça se sent deux
élus de gauche et puis à droite et bien
il y avait 10ans celui qui a été le
mieux élu je dirais et sans surprise
c'était herbereno le maire de
Saint-Chamond également vice Premier
vice-président de Saint-Étienne
Métropole et une petite donc ces deux
mandats pour devenir sénateur il aurait
aimé être accompagné par Clotilde Robin
qui est une élue du rouennais et bien
non ce sera le divers droites et donc
divergent Pierre-Jean Rochette et qui a
donc semé un petit peu le trouble du
côté de la droite et notamment Hervé
Réno qui regrettait et bien qu'il avance
masquer parce qu'il est soutenu par la
majorité présidentielle sans être sans y
être investi merci beaucoup merci
Anthony verpillon merci aux équipes de
TL7 la télévision locale de la Loire
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous parler
de ses dans votre département le Parti
communiste on disait avant ces élections
qu'il était en danger que son groupe
était en danger finalement il sort
renforcé et là aussi il y avait une
bataille au sein de la gauche
sanatoriale en précologie c'était
communiste pour savoir qui serait le
deuxième groupe derrière le PS oui
aujourd'hui en effet le Parti communiste
a une petite tête d'avance même s'il va
falloir voir il y a plusieurs élus
notamment le tramarin c'est pas
notamment ce qui va être du nouvel élu
néo calédonien donc il y a encore des
jeux à la marche qui peuvent entraîner
une forme d'évolution toutefois son
effet une grande victoire pour le CRCE
hier soir on a un groupe qui augmente
exactement on a un groupe qui augmente
et on a un groupe qui par définition va
peser encore un peu plus au sein de la
gauche une gauche qui se rééquilibre
plutôt à son avantage donc pour les
communistes c'est une belle soirée
la gauche sénatoriale qui
vise
dans l'ancienne l'objectif peut être
atteint l'objectif en effet peut être
atteint il va falloir voir les derniers
résultats notamment venant de
l'outre-mer après le chiffre est
symbolique il faut quand même voir que
sur le temps long on a quand même plutôt
une érosion de l'ensemble de la gauche
les 100 sénateurs c'est ce que pouvait
faire le groupe socialiste au moment du
basculement du Sénat de 2011 à 2014 vous
voyez qu'il y a quand même une érosion
fondamentalement et que cette érosion là
elle signifie une recomposition du
paysage politique certes les choses
évoluent l'entrée au Sénat elles
évoluent quand même merci Benjamin Morel
merci à vous d'avoir été avec plaisir
pour une première de ces résultats vous
revenez évidemment régulièrement dans ce
club
merci beaucoup de notre édition spéciale
consacrée à ce résultat des sénatoriales